Olaf Scholz und dem ukrainischen
Präsidenten selenski
das ist ein starkes Signal dich heute
hier in unserer Hauptstadt zu begrüßen
dutzende Mal haben wir in den
vergangenen anderthalb Jahren
miteinander telefoniert mehrmals sind
wir uns begegnet in tief in Brüssel in
Paris und in München hier in Berlin ist
es aber unser erstes Treffen und darüber
freue ich mich sehr trotz der
schwierigen furchtbaren Umstände die uns
hier zusammenführen seit 444 Tagen läuft
der erbarmungslose russische
Angriffskrieg gegen dein Land seit 444
Tagen stellen sich die Ukraine und
Ukraine unbeugsam und heldenhaft dieser
brutalen Aggression Russlands entgegen
dafür gebührt euch all unser Respekt und
auch unsere Anerkennung
dieser schreckliche Krieg hat erhebliche
geopolitische Konsequenzen
zuallererst aber betrifft er die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger der Ukraine mehr
als eine Million von ihnen vor allem
Frauen Kinder und ältere haben hier in
Deutschland Schutz gefunden
wir hier in Deutschland unsere
Bürgerinnen und Bürger stehen in voller
Solidarität zu den Menschen die vor den
brutalen Angriffen hierher geflohen sind
diese Solidarität sie ist anhaltend und
sie ist stark
die enge Verbindung wird die Beziehung
unserer beiden Länder zueinander auf
Jahrzehnte hinaus prägen im angesichts
des Schreckens des Himmel scheinen
Unrechts rücken wir noch enger zusammen
wir unterstützen die Ukraine nicht nur
humanitär sondern auch politisch
finanziell und natürlich auch mit Waffen
ich habe es oft gesagt und wiederhole es
hier heute wir unterstützen euch so
lange wie es nötig sein wird
seit Beginn des Krieges beläuft sich
allein unsere bilaterale Unterstützung
der Ukraine auf 17 Milliarden Euro und
wir haben die Weichen dafür gestellt
dass diese Hilfe auch in den nächsten
Jahren sichergestellt wird
militärisch liefern wir sehr moderne und
wirksame Waffen mit denen ihr euch
verteidigen könnt
beispielsweise Kampfpanzer vom Typ
Leopard 2 A6
Schützenpanzer Marder die System
zur Luftverteidigung
flugabwehrpanzer Panzerhaubitzen
mehrfach Raketenwerfer und viel Munition
und wir lassen in unserer Unterstützung
nicht nach gerade haben wir entschieden
ein neues Unterstützungspaket für
Militärgerät zu schnüren in einem
Gesamtwert von 2,7 Milliarden Euro die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte werden weitere
Kampfpanzer vom Typ Leopard 1 weitere
Schützenpanzer Marder und aristine
erhalten
wir sehen all die schrecklichen Berichte
und deswegen ist klar die
Verantwortlichen für diesen
fürchterlichen Angriffskrieg müssen zur
Rechenschaft gezogen werden keinen Staat
der Welt darf ein anderes Land
überfallen niemand darf Morden plündern
Kinder entführen
deswegen setzen wir uns gemeinsam mit
unseren Partnern dafür ein dass Russland
über einen für seine Untaten
für seine Untaten zur Rechenschaft
gezogen wird
lieber Wladimir ich freue mich dass wir
nachher gemeinsam nach Aachen fliegen
und dir und dem ukrainischen Volk der
internationale Karlspreis verliehen wird
wenn nicht die Ukraine hätte diese
Auszeichnung dieses Jahr verdient vielen
Dank für deinen Besuch
vielen Dank Olaf
war eine Kanzlerin sehr verehrter
Bundeskanzler
Journalisten und anwesende
deutsches Volk vor allem möchte ich dir
Olaf herzlich danken
und dem gesamten deutschen
Volk für eure Hilfe für jedes gerettete
ukrainische Leben ich möchte
unterstreichen die Hilfe Deutschlands
das ist Schutz Schutz des Lebens der
Menschen die dort leben
Schutz Verteidigung der Menschen die das
Verteidigen
was sie haben mit Hilfe von
Luftverteidigung und Luftabwehr
damit das soziale Leben in der Ukraine
Hilfe ist sehr wichtig
ukrainische Volk wird immer dankbar sein
dafür den deutschen Volk und für durch
deine
Führungskraft
Deutschlands und deine Olaf
ist die Chance gegeben die Welt sicherer
zu machen und
je mehr Deutschland hier führend ist
desto besser ist das für den Frieden in
der Welt
desto mehr Stabilität wird es geben in
den internationalen Beziehungen sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
gerade jetzt möchten wir alle dass
dieser Krieg so schnell wie möglich zu
Ende geht aber er muss zu Ende gehen mit
einem gerechten Frieden
unsere territoriale Integrität und die
Sicherheit sind genauso wichtig wie die
territoriale Integrität aller
Völker und gerade jetzt bereits in
diesem Jahr
haben wir
rechnen wir damit dass dieser Krieg zu
Ende geht und wir können die Niederlage
deshalb besiegeln
das neue
Unterstützungspaket von deutscher Seite
über 2,7 Milliarden Euro das ist eine
sehr wichtige und starke Hilfe vielen
Dank Olaf dafür
das sind
Luftabwehrsysteme Granaten Haubitzen
Bundeskanzler hat bereits dazu
gesprochen aber in diesem
Sicherheitspaket ist die Möglichkeit uns
zu schützen und zu verteidigen gegen die
russischen Angreifer
Deutschland hat über 11 Milliarden Euro
bereitgestellt um in diesem Jahr die
Sicherheit der Ukraine zu stärken und
die Beteiligung Deutschlands auch an der
europäischen Fritz facilität zählt
hierzu das zeigt den Willen des
deutschen Volkes die Freiheit zu
verteidigen und der Umfang der deutschen
Hilfe ist die zweitgrößte nach den USA
das ist sehr sehr viel
und
wir haben mit dem Bundeskanzler über die
Lage in der Kampfzone gesprochen über
die Situation an der Front die
Kampfhandlungen werden weitergehen wir
haben darüber gesprochen was wir zur
Umsetzung unserer friedensformel
Vorhaben für die Stabilität und Ruhe in
den internationalen Beziehungen wir
haben unsere Positionen abgestimmt im
Rahmen der G7 und die Wege auf die wir
hoffen von Seiten der Weltgemeinschaft
Gefahr die immer noch existent ist
wir sehen in Deutschland einen
deutschen eine deutsche Hilfe und die
Ukraine ist ein Land das ich als
europäisches Land sieht und ich denke
wir haben uns auch einen Anspruch darauf
verarbeitet als europäisches Land und
als Land unter anderem europäischen
Völkern zu sein ich möchte nicht
bedanken bei allen deutschen Familien
bei jedem deutschen Steuerzahler für
jede bei jeder Stadt und bei jedem
Bundesland
für die
Unterstützung unserer Menschen die
Schutz gefunden haben in Deutschland
als sie sich vor den russischen
Anschlägen auf unser Land gerettet haben
und diese Worte des Dankes
möchte man jeden Tag sagen danke für
jede Mutter für jedes Kind dass sie
gerettet haben und der Ukraine
[Musik]
vielen Dank herr Präsident Sie haben es
eben schon gesagt Deutschland hat Ihnen
ein sehr umfangreiches waffenpaket
zugesagt sie haben das als ein starkes
Zeichen bezeichnet was dieses
waffenpaket nicht enthält sind
Kampfjets westlicher Bauart die die
Ukraine schon seit vielen Monaten
fordert was erwarten Sie davon
Deutschland erwarten Sie das Deutschland
selbst Kampfjets liefert also
Eurofighter oder Tornados oder erwarten
Sie zumindest dass Deutschland sie bei
den Bemühungen unterstützt von den USA
F16 Kampfjets zu erhalten und eine
zweite Frage wenn Sie erlauben stimmen
die Berichte dass sie planen russisches
Territorium anzugreifen um sich in eine
bessere Verhandlungsposition zu bringen
und der Bundeskanzler das neue
waffenpaket enthält er jetzt
Waffen derselben Qualität die
Deutschland bereits geliefert hat sind
sie bereit in Zukunft auch noch einmal
Waffen neuer Qualität zu liefern also
Kampfjets oder auch
Marschflugkörper oder
halten sie eben die Befürchtung dass die
Ukraine Russland damit angreifen können
könnte von seiner solchen Entscheidung
ab
vielen Dank für die Frage
zu allererste wenn es um Kampfflugzeuge
gibt
ich
denke dass es darum im zweiten Teil
unseres Gesprächs gehen wird wir
arbeiten jetzt daran eine Kampfjet
Koalition zu
schaffen unter anderem während meines
Besuches in den europäischen
Hauptstädten der dient unter anderem
diesem ich denke ich werde mich auch an
die deutsche Seite wenden mit der Bitte
uns hier in dieser Koalition zu
unterstützen das ist für die Ukraine
sehr wichtig unsere anstrengend zu
koordinieren
und
heute hat Russland doch ein übergewichte
im Luftraum das wollen wir überwinden
und was das Eindringen
betrifft
ich
dort wo ich hinkomme komme ich offiziell
hin und ich bringe nirgends ein das kann
ich dazu sagen
ja schönen Dank für die Frage wir haben
in der Tat sehr viel geliefert was wir
schon geliefert haben aber darum geht es
jetzt auch ganz konkret bei der
geplanten Offensive der Ukraine geht es
auch bei der Verteidigung des eigenen
Landes und der dem
massiven Versuch sicherzustellen das
Russland seine Truppen zurückzieht darum
geht es wenn wir den Frieden in der
Ukraine sichern wollen und wir haben
sehr viel geliefert gerade was die
Luftverteidigung betrifft sind das sehr
moderne Waffen mit dem patriot-system
mit ihres irishi was wir zur Verfügung
stellen was auch sehr wirksam ist mit
dem lackpanzer Gepard und mit vielen
kleineren Waffen die genau diesem Zweck
dienen genauso wie die vielfältigen Form
der atillerie die wir zur Verfügung
stellen und das ist das worauf wir uns
als deutsche jetzt konzentrieren
sie haben früher gesagt dass sie mehr
Zeit brauchen für den Gegenangriff
und nun gab es ja Ankündigung für das
neue Paket reicht das nun aus damit die
Ukraine tatsächlich zum Gegenangriff
übergehen kann oder
muss das so sein
and future membership enigator so ist
Germany ready to private
for future Member privat
[Musik]
noch einige Besucher und dann ist es
ausreichend
viel Erfolg
aber die
entscheidende Aussage ist natürlich wir
haben jetzt eine Aufgabe die darin
besteht die Ukraine bei einem
Verteidigungskampf zu unterstützen das
ist das was wir machen und der Präsident
hat es eben gesagt deutschland ist nach
den USA jetzt der zweitgrößte
Unterstützer der Ukraine wir werden das
auch weiter bleiben das macht ja die
Größe des Pakets über das wir eben
gesprochen haben von jetzt noch einmal
einer erheblichen Milliarden Summe
deutlich wir sind auch ganz klar in
unserer Botschaft gegenüber der Ukraine
aber mindestens auch an den russischen
Aggressor wir werden die Ukraine so
lange unterstützen wie das notwendig ist
das heißt wir sind wir hoffen dass der
Krieg schnell ein Ende findet auch weil
es gelingt mit der militärischen mit der
Waffen Unterstützung mit Waffen die
Ukraine die Lage zu versetzen ihr Land
zu verteidigen aber wir bereiten uns vor
und bereiten auch alle unsere Freunde
und Partner darauf vor dass wir lange
unterstützen können wenn und soweit das
notwendig ist und das ist glaube ich die
wichtige Aussage die man machen kann
ansonsten ist es so dass wenn wir uns
darauf jetzt konzentrieren den
russischen Angriff zurück zu dass die in
russischen Angriff zurückweisen kann
dann geht es um praktische Fragen und
alles andere ist ja
existierende Beschlusslage aus Bukarest
deutsche Presse christina hat uns
redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland
eine Frage an Sie beide Herr
Bundeskanzler und herr Präsident das
deutsch-ukrainische Verhältnis gilt als
belastet zum einen weil ihre Partei Herr
Bundeskanzler lange ein enges Verhältnis
zu Russland hatte und sie
Waffenlieferungen immer intensiv geprüft
haben bevor Sie zugestimmt haben ist das
mit dem heutigen Treffen und dem
erneuten waffenpaket endgültig
ausgeräumt haben sie vertrauen herr
Präsident und ich habe gerade ihre
Antworten nicht ganz genau verstanden
auf die Frage ob
ukrainische Kräfte auf russisches Gebiet
schießen könnten herr Präsident Sie
haben gesagt sie kommen überall dorthin
wo sie offiziell hinkommen bedeutet das
Angriffe auf die Krim und Herr
Bundeskanzler würden sie das mit Waffen
die soweit reichen auch unterstützen und
dann habe ich noch eine Frage herr
Präsident es gibt in Deutschland einen
Teil von Menschen den es sehr schwer
fällt ihre Nähe zu Russland aufzugeben
und man hört auch unter ukrainischen
geflüchteten Kummer über zerbrochene
Freundschaften kann es für sie
irgendwann Versöhnung geben
vielen Dank
für diese ganze Fragenliste
ich weiß gar nicht womit ich beginnen
soll
wahrscheinlich damit
irgendwelche Lieferungen gebremst werden
ich denke wir sind heute im Krieg und
sind sehr dankbar für die deutsche und
der Hilfe wie der Kanzler gesagt hat und
ich kann das bestätigen dass Deutschland
heute an zweiter Stelle steht in der
Unterstützung und ich denke wir werden
daran arbeiten dass wir Deutschland auf
den ersten Platz bringen in der
Unterstützung aber
was russisches Territorium betrifft
wir greifen kein russisches Gebiet an
wir befreien unsere legitimen Gebiete
wir haben dazu weder Zeit noch Kraft und
wir haben auch keine Waffen übrig mit
denen wir das tun könnten wir bereiten
einen Gegenangriff vor zur Portion der
Team eroberten Gebiete gemäß unserer
Verfassung
im Rahmen unserer legitimen Grenzen die
weltweit anerkannt sind danke schönen
Dank
der Präsident hat ja beantwortet was
seine Pläne sind deshalb erübrigt sich
ja die Frage Antwort auf die Frage die
sie gestellt haben und wir haben bisher
Waffen geliefert die genau für diesen
Zweck dienen nämlich die Verteidigung
der Ukraine dass sie in der Lage ist den
Angriff auf das eigene Land
zurückzuweisen und auch ihr eigenes
Territorium zu verteidigen und genau
darum geht es auch bei dem was wir
weitermachen die größte der
Waffenlieferung die Deutschland zur
Verfügung stellt und die Qualität dieser
Waffen ist ja schon beschrieben worden
ich will ergänzen dass das bei uns ja
auch noch viele andere Komponenten
beinhaltet die nicht immer im Fokus
stehen z.B sehr viel Mühe mit der
Ausbildung der ukrainischen Soldaten
Soldaten hierzulande zum Beispiel indem
wir sowohl in Deutschland als auch in
den Nachbarländern der Ukraine Service
hat eingerichtet haben die die ständige
Temperatur der verschiedenen
Waffensysteme nötig macht das ist ja
vielleicht etwas was manche nicht im
Blick haben aber eine erfolgreiche
Verteidigung setzt voraus dass man seine
Waffen auch permanent einsetzen kann und
das setzt ein etabliertes
funktionierendes gut organisiertes
reparaturregime voraus dass wir jetzt an
vielen Stellen zum Beispiel in Polen in
der Slowakei und in Rumänien etabliert
haben und wir werden auch weiter daran
arbeiten genau das zu gewährleisten
übrigens auch was die Frage betrifft der
munitionslieferung die eine große Rolle
spielen im übrigen bin ich sehr sicher
dass die Beziehung zwischen der Ukraine
und Deutschland sehr sehr gut sind das
spiegelt sich nicht nur wieder in
unserer enger Freundschaft und engen
Kooperationen und der Offenheit in der
wir alle Fragen sehr gut sprechen
sondern das spiegelt sich auch wieder
zwischen unseren beiden Ländern dass
Deutschland so viel an Unterstützung im
militärischer Hinsicht leistet wird ja
getragen von einer großen Zahl von
Bürgern und Bürgern die selber helfen
die eine Million hier registrierten
ukrainischen Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu
unterstützen das ist ja nicht nur eine
Verwaltungsangelegenheit das ist etwas
was eine zivile Bewegung darstellt von
vielen Bürgern und Bürgern meines Landes
Familien die Ukrainisch Familien
aufgenommen haben Erzieherinnen und
Erzieher Lehrerinnen und Lehrer die sich
ganz viel Mühe in den Schulen geben ganz
viele Initiativen für
Freizeitaktivitäten für Aktivitäten der
beruflichen Integration die jeden Tag
stattfinden und deshalb bin ich ganz
sicher dass es in Deutschland eine
stabile klare Unterstützung für den Kurs
der Bundesregierung gibt die Ukraine so
zu unterstützen und das beinhaltet auch
dass wir das behutsam und klug abgewogen
machen und die Tatsache dass wir das
gemacht haben ist vielleicht auch die
Ursache dafür warum die Unterstützung in
Deutschland anders als in dem ein oder
anderen Land ungebrochen hoch ist
die letzte Frage
gehört zur
zufriedensgesprächen und zur Richtung
eines gerechten Friedens so war die
Formulierung tatsächlich wir haben als
ähm
noch nicht gesehen woher diese Meldungen
genau kommen vor allem ist für uns ähm
interessant zu hören was unsere Partner
unter einem gerechten Frieden verstehen
bedeutet das Mitgliedschaft in der Natur
in der EU und eine
Präzisierung das ist tatsächlich so dass
vom Erfolg der gegen das Gegenangriff
abhängen wird ob er Waffen geliefert
werden an den Bundeskanzler eine Frage
sie haben auch zur politischen
Beteiligung Deutschlands gesprochen am
an der Beendigung des Krieges heißt das
dass Deutschland dafür stimmen wird dass
die Ukraine der EU-Mitglied wird
und haben die heute dem Präsidenten
Vorschläge unterbreitet zur Beendigung
der Aggression gegen die Ukraine
vielen Dank zuerst einmal ist es so dass
der Krieg auf unserem Hoheitsgebiet
abläuft und deshalb ist es so dass jeder
Friedensplan den es gibt sich auf eine
Initiative der Ukraine berufen können
muss und den habe ich in Indonesien beim
G20 vorgestellt wir haben darüber mit
dem Kanzler gesprochen er wird seine
Gedanken dazu
äußern aber ich denke wir haben die
gleiche Position und was andere Staaten
anbetrifft die ihre Angebote dort
unterbreitet haben und das Willen wir
brauchen nicht viele Pläne wir haben
einen Krieg der nur auf unserem Gebiete
stattfindet und deshalb ist es so dass
wir bereit sind Initiativen mir
jeglichen Landes uns anzuhören und nicht
nur anzuhören
je mehr Staaten sich beteiligen
die auch an Gipfel zur friedensformel
den zehn Punkteplan der Ukraine
teilnehmen werden wir werden sehen wer
dort teilnehmen wird
dort
sehen wir
Krisenmanagement aber dennoch ist uns
klar dass der Krieg immer noch
weitergeht und natürlich ergeben sich
damit auch Veränderung wir sind bereit
jegliche Vorschläge zu
besprechen aber nur auf
der Plattform die wir anbieten und was
den bewaffneten Kampf an betrifft es
gibt das Risiko
wenn die
gegenwände gegen Angriff nicht
ausreichend erfolgreich ist
dass dann einige Staaten eventuell
darüber nachdenken
aber ich denke
die Hilfe dieser Staaten war bisher auch
nicht so umfangreich
das
ungeachtet glauben wir alle an einen
Erfolg und denken nicht an andere Sachen
wir glauben daran dass der Erfolg
unserer sein wird wir sind motiviert und
ich denke dass wir
fast bereit sind zu diesem Erfolg
schönen Dank für die Frage in der Tat
wir werden die Ukrain unterstützen und
das muss überall und in der ganzen Welt
auch gesagt werden die Ukraine ist
bereit zu einem Frieden allerdings
verlangt die Ukraine schon zu recht und
völlig mit unserer Unterstützung dass
das nicht bedeuten kann einfach den
Krieg einzufrieren und das ein
diktatfrieden von russischer Seite
formuliert wird es handelt sich um ein
imperialistischen Angriff auf
ukrainisches Territorium und der Frieden
und die Sicherheit in Europa sind
bedroht von der Idee dass ein mächtiges
Land ein weniger mächtiges Land
angreifen kann und sich einfach ein Teil
seines Territoriums einverleiben kann
die Pläne des russischen Präsidenten
sind auch offensichtlich man muss seine
Schriften lesen seine öffentlichen Reden
hören er denkt eigentlich dass Belarus
und die Ukraine von ihm zu Russland
gemacht werden müssen oder möglichst
viele Teile davon und der Angriff auf
die Ukraine ist Teil dieses
imperialistischen Konzepts und das ist
wiederum etwas was in der Welt sehr
genau verstanden wird wir haben
erfolgreiche Abstimmung gehabt bei den
Vereinten Nationen zu Verurteilung der
russischen Aggression aber auch viele
von den Staaten die sich enthalten haben
die nicht mit abgestimmt haben
verurteilen die russische Aggression sie
sind manchmal unmittelbarer
Nachbarschaft und halten sich zurück sie
sind manchmal weit weg und sehen die
Folgen und halten sich zurück aber an
der Tatsache dass das nicht
funktionieren kann das mit Gewalt
Grenzen verschoben werden daran gibt es
nur wenig Zweifel in der Welt und
deshalb glaube ich auch dass ausgehen
von dem Vorschlag des Präsidenten was
die Möglichkeit eines Friedens betrifft
alle Diskussionen sich darum drehen
müssen dass diese Möglichkeiten
verstanden wird und das immer klar ist
Russland muss Truppen zurückziehen ohne
das wird es nicht gehen und diese
Botschaft versuche ich übrigens auch in
meinen Gesprächen mit den Ländern der
Geld zu vertreten und zu unterstreichen
ich glaube dass das ganz bedeutendes und
da kommt Deutschland Europa da kommt den
USA eine große Rolle zu wir müssen den
Ländern im Süden Amerikas in Afrika und
den Asien sagen es gibt keine
Doppelstandards die Probleme die in
ihren Ländern existieren berühren uns
gleichermaßen Angriffe eines mächtigen
Landes auf ein Nachbarland sind auch
dann ein Problem für uns wenn es weit
weg von uns selber ist und wir kümmern
uns auch um die Auswirkungen die der
russische Angriff für die ganze Welt hat
den nahrungsmittelunsicherheit steigende
Preise sind Probleme mit dem viele
Länder zu kämpfen haben aber die Ursache
dafür liegt in Moskau das ist das was
wir versuchen zu sagen und deshalb bin
ich ganz sicher dass es gut ist wenn
auch andere Länder sich um ein Frieden
bemühen aber dass sie auch immer klar im
Blick haben das geht nicht gegen die
Ukraine und es bedeutet Russland muss
Truppen zurückziehen
[Musik]
Kanzleramt in Berlin anlässlich des
Besuchs des ukrainischen Präsidenten
selenski bei Bundeskanzler Scholz
und bei mir im Studio ist weiter der
Sicherheitsexperte der Bonner
Universität Joachim Weber
diese Pressekonferenz begann damit das
wieder über Kampfjets gesprochen wurde
ich erinnere mich dass wir vor ungefähr
einem halben Jahr über Panzer über
verschiedene Panzer Lieferungen Panzer
Gattungen gesprochen haben aber beim
Wort Kampfjets haben sie sehr gebremst
und gesagt dass das wäre eine Grenze die
wir nicht überschreiten sollten das ist
ein halbes Jahr her es war bisher immer
so dass jede Waffengattung nach ein paar
Monaten sozusagen eingeführt war im
Sprachgebrauch und später auch in der
Wirklichkeit wie wird es diesmal sein
also wenn der Trend so anhält den wir ja
als stabilen Trend jetzt seit vielen
vielen Monaten sehen dann wird auch
diese
kampfjetgrenze überschritten werden ich
wusste nicht mit welchen Argumenten man
dann noch dagegen vorgehen sollte denn
dann ist das gesamte Arsenal moderner
Kriegswaffen ausgeschöpft mehr gibt es
dann eigentlich auch nicht dann hat also
die Ukraine sozusagen alles was es gibt
da kann man dafür sein da kann man
dagegen sein es unerfreuliche ist und
bleibt dass wir rein weiter ins in einer
Situation bewegen die nur den
militärischen Faden folgt und vielleicht
kann das im Moment noch gar nicht anders
sein weil beide Seiten im Moment noch
keinen Interesse daran haben dass der
Krieg so endet wie er jetzt steht aber
wir müssen irgendwann wieder zu einer
politischen Lösung kommen das jetzt
politische Gespräche voraus dass jetzt
voraus sein Gegenüber auch in diesem
Fall die Russen ernst zu nehmen viele
sagen ja dann schnell dahin ja mit
Verbrechern kann man nicht verhandeln
oder irgendetwas aber was nützt denn das
nicht da ist nun mal ein Land von über
140 Millionen das hat eine starke
Führung die wird nach wie vor von großen
Teilen der Bevölkerung getragen und es
wird nicht gehen ohne dass man in
irgendeiner Weise zu irgendeinem
Zeitpunkt auch irgendeine Weise ins
Gespräch miteinander kommt
sie haben die ganzen Vormittag jetzt den
Besuch des ukrainischen Präsidenten in
Berlin verfolgt heute Nachmittag reist
der weiter nach Aachen bekommt in
Karlspreis wie war ja Eindruck von den
Beziehungen die da sind und die da
vielleicht vertieft wurden vielleicht
weiter neu entstanden sind wie würden
sie das bilanzieren also im Vergleich
mit anderen Staatsbesuchen von silensky
die man gesehen hat wirkt es alles noch
ein bisschen unterkühlt in Berlin
zumindest jetzt beim Kanzler hat man ja
mal dann einen Lächeln und ein bisschen
emotionale Bewegung gesehen dass das
nicht alles nur mechanistisch da
abgespult worden ist aber man hat nicht
das Gefühl dass es dieselbe herzliche
Intensität der Beziehung ist vielleicht
wie zu Großbritannien oder den USA
das kann man jetzt auch gut oder
schlecht finden aber wenn die neuesten
Zahlen stimmen eben hieß es ist
Deutschland ist jetzt schon der
zweitstärkste waffensteller das würde
bedeuten dass wir groß Britannien
überholt hätten das kann seinem Sinne
der neuesten Zahlen man muss sich das
jetzt mal genau anschauen und dann mal
wieder saldieren
dann wäre das eine bemerkenswerte
Entwicklung denn man muss vielleicht
noch mal wieder wiederholen an dieser
Stelle die USA und Großbritannien sind
die signathermächte des Budapest haben
wir Randoms sie haben die Ukraine zu
verteidigen sie haben sich dazu
verpflichtet Deutschland ist dann nicht
verpflichtet so aus keinem abkommen kann
gar nichts tut das aber richtigerweise
wie ich denke unterstützt die Ukraine
aber ob wir immer weiter jetzt ist es ja
von selenski er möchte Deutschland
irgendwie an Nummer eins der
Waffenlieferung irgendwann sehen da muss
ich natürlich auch die deutsche Politik
irgendwann fragen lassen ist das der
richtige Weg auf dem Werder sind also
müssen wir uns auch von außen sagen dass
man welcher Stelle wir stehen wollen das
sind vielleicht ein paar Dinge die wir
sehr sorgsam mal überlegen sollten
vielen Dank für diese Einordnungen
Joachim Weber Sicherheitsexperte der
bundesität danke sehr gerne
ja und der der keine Präsident reist
jetzt weiter nach Aachen mit ihm der
Bundeskanzler als sein Gastgeber in
Deutschland und wir wollen gerne kurz
nach Aachen schalten um zu hören wie es
denn dort steht heute Nachmittag ist
dort die karlspreisverleihung ich
begrüße michaelsen
hallo Thomas Bade
Karlspreis ist ja jedes Jahr ein großes
Ereignis aber in diesem Jahr vielleicht
noch ein bisschen größer warum wie
bereitet Aachen sich jetzt vor
hat zunächst einmal muss man sagen dass
jetzt wahrscheinlich sehr viele hier
erleichtert sind dass sie jetzt die
Bestätigung offiziell aus dem Munde des
Kanzlers bekommen haben dass Lenski
tatsächlich heute Nachmittag hier nach
Aachen kommt denn diese offizielle
Bestätigung die hat es bisher nicht
gegeben nichtsdestotrotz wurde hier
alles vorbereitet für den Fall dass er
kommt der Fall der jetzt auch eintreten
wird ich habe das schon gesehen auf dem
Weg hier nach Aachen hin also ungefähr
10 km vor Aachen schon auf jeder
Autobahnbrücke standen Polizeiautos wir
kamen unterwegs seinen Konvoi von
Motorrädern entgegen wahrscheinlich um
silenski und den Kanzler von irgendeinem
Flughafen hier in der Gegend dann
abzuholen und hier nach Aachen zu
bringen Aachen selbst ist eine absolute
Sicherheitszone die Innenstadt ja sie
ist weil es wird gesagt selbst als
Präsident Clinton 2000 den Karlspreis
hier bekommen hat wäre nicht so ein
Sicherheitsaufwand betrieben worden wie
jetzt die Kanaldeckel sind versiegelt
worden man ist tatsächlich auch noch mal
in die Kanalisation runtergegangen hat
geguckt ob dort nicht irgendwelche
Spuren von Sprengstoff sind und 1000
Polizisten sollen hier im Einsatz sein
und alles in der Aachener Innenstadt wir
stehen jetzt hier gerade ganz am Rand
aber in der Innenstadt selber
abgeriegelt kein Publikumsverkehr für
die Anwohner natürlich eine enorme
Einschränkung aber man kann sagen Aachen
freut sich darauf tatsächlich dass heute
silensky hierhin kommt es gibt
Demonstration einige
Friedensdemonstrationen die für die
Unterstützung der Ukraine sind aber
natürlich auch eine Gegendemonstration
kleinere Art ich habe das gerade auf dem
Weg hierhin schon gesehen auch das wird
von der Polizei begleitet also insofern
Aachen hat sich vorbereitet und Aachen
freut sich darauf heute Nachmittag so
prominente Gäste hier begrüßen zu können
und tatsächlich scheint der hohe sicher
als Aufwand äh gerechtfertigt denn
immerhin Präsident der Lenski ist der
Präsident eines Landes dass sich im
Krieg befindet er ist schon im eigenen
Land die ständigen gefahren aber
möglicherweise sogar noch mehr im
Ausland wo er eben nicht in dem Maße in
seinen eigenen Grenzen geschützt wird
wie das in der Ukraine der Fall ist der
Bundeskanzler hat ja neben den
organisatorischen Dingen auch noch etwas
inhaltlich dazu gesagt wer nicht wer
wenn nicht der ukrainische Präsident
sollte den Preis jetzt bekommen wer
hätte ihn mehr verdient als dieser
Präsident und seine Bevölkerung wird das
von den Menschen auch so empfunden
Moment kein Ton mehr aber keine
tonstellung ich habe soll ich die Frage
nochmal wiederholen oder haben sie es
konnten sie es hören eben ich habe
sinngemäß mitbekommen
die Antwort wäre ich meine das sieht man
ja auch in der Begründung für den
Karlspreis es wird gesagt selensky es
bekommt ja nicht nur selenski sondern
auch das ukrainische Volk in Karlspreis
aber gerade die Personen silenski darin
konzentriert sich ja sehr viel was in
Widerstandsgeist die Widerstandskraft
ist ukrainischen Volkes ausmacht das
wird gesagt er der Präsident sei der
Motor er sei der Kommunikator ist er der
Motivator er sei die Klammer zwischen
dem ukrainischen Volk und der verlangt
der Unterstützer von außen also all den
Ländern wie jetzt auch Deutschland die
der Ukraine Unterstützung zu kommen
lassen all das ist ganz eindeutig an die
Begründung für den Karlspreis andersrum
soll aber von dieser Verleihung auch das
Signal ausgehen dass die Europäer die
Ukraine weiter unterstützen müssen und
das ist das Signal was wahrscheinlich
auch am Ende des Tages von Aachen dann
auch stehen bleiben wird
dass silensky hier im Schoß sozusagen
Europas diesen Preis bekommt sind auch
andere Politiker dabei Ursula von der
Leyen wird eine Rede halten der
polnische Ministerpräsident wird hier
sein es gab zwischendurch auch mal
Gerüchte ob vielleicht sogar Frankreichs
Präsident macron kommen wird diese
Gerüchte haben sich aber nicht bestätigt
aber es ist trotzdem sage ich mal so
dass hushu der europäischen Elite ist
hier vertreten und das muss dem
Präsidenten aber auch dem ukrainischen
Volk ja das Signal geben wir Europa
stehen hinter euch egal was dort
passiert wir sind bei euch wir
unterstützen euch in diesem Krieg in der
Hoffnung dass es dann doch irgendwann
mal zu einem Frieden kommen wird und
auch Russland sich drauf sind dass es ja
zum Teil zumindest auch ein Teil Europas
ist Michael Häuschen vielen Dank für
diese Einstimmung auf die Verleihung des
karlspreises an den ukrainischen
Präsidenten selenski und seine
Bevölkerung heute Nachmittag in Aachen
und pHOENIX überträgt es der
Westdeutsche Rundfunk überträgt das ab
15 Uhr können Sie liebe Zuschauer und
Zuschauer das im Fernsehen mit verfolgen
und es wird mit Sicherheit ein würdiger
und historischer Nachmittag
bevor ich jetzt diese Sendung hier
beende möchte ich noch einmal sagen wir
sind ja vorhin aus einer Sendung
rausgegangen wir sind rausgegangen dass
der Sendung Phönix persönlich mit dem
luxemburgischen Außenministerin und die
geht natürlich nicht verloren um 14 Uhr
um 14 Uhr läuft